- I just moved here to
New York and I love it.
And you're from here,
Hell's Kitchen, right?
- Yeah.
I'm just down the street,
can you believe it?
- Yeah.
Did you enjoy this city at all growing up?
Do you like the energy?
- No, I didn't
because it was very rough back then.
Back then they actually,
it was called Hell's Kitchen for a reason.
It's because at that time
a lot of different people
lived in the neighborhood
and they would cook,
because it's so hot they
would cook on the balconies.
So it smelled like hell's
kitchen 'cause you had cabbage
with beans.
- Is that how it got the name?
- Yeah, that's how the name
came, yeah, yeah.
- I didn't know that.
Oh, you learn something new every day.
- Now you know.
- You're just bestowing
knowledge left and right.
I like it.
- Thank you.
- Well, in the documentary,
like you talk about pain and regret,
and that's like what the
character is going through.
But a lot of people relate to that.
So how do you deal with
pain or regret in your life?
- Well, you just have to
say it's going to be there.
It's never going to go away.
- [Kelly] Inevitable, yeah.
- And I think you just
understand, you have to accept it.
It's part of your history,
part of your culture,
and, okay, I know it's gonna
arrive but I'm prepared for it
and it will pass.
It's like a bad storm.
- Yeah.
- It's just,
but I think people become
disillusioned when they,
oh well, I sought medical
help, I've seen a psychiatrist,
and they think their
history's going to vanish.
- No.
- And it doesn't, no.
But in some ways it can
be a motivating force.
- [Kelly] Hell, yeah.
- You know, even though it
started like as a negative,
it can eventually end up as a positive
if you use it instead of internalizing it.
- Use it for fuel
for your fire, yeah.
- Yeah, I think so, yeah.
But like what you do,
you entertain people.
And when you're being entertained
is when you kinda forget your problems
for two hours, three hours,
you know what I mean?
- Why do you think I have nine jobs?
(Kelly, Sylvester, and audience laugh)
- Is that one reason?
- I'm like, busy, busy bee.
Yeah.
- [Sylvester] That's funny.
- I do like being busy though,
and I think that is a
thing from childhood.
Like, I'm like, okay, I
must be productive in it.
Not that it necessarily keeps it at bay,
but I think it gives you a break
to maybe get some perspective
and listen to other people.
- Oh, absolutely.
There's no question.
I think, yeah, the more you
keep yourself motivated,
the better off it is.
- Yeah, I heard that you said
"Rocky" couldn't have existed
without Carl Weathers, right?
- No, you know?
First of all, Rocky the, oh I know.
- [Kelly] Look at that
photo, it's so iconic, wow.
- [Sylvester] Yeah?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah, he was amazing.
I couldn't find anyone to play the part.
No one had all the tools.
Either their voice was too
high or they weren't big enough
or they weren't athletic enough.
It's really hard to find
everything in a person.
So it was about eight o'clock at night
and the guy I wanted, (chuckles) he quit
because he wants to go in
a bicycle race competition.
I went "Really?"
So obviously he was not a serious actor.
- Yeah
- He was a physical type.
So I'm sitting there and
at 8:30 this fella comes in
and he's mad, like, "What
am I here for, I mean."
'Cause no one gets it, like,
you don't have an audition
at 8:30 at night, you're like
at the bottom of the barrel,
you know what I mean?
- Oh.
- You know what I mean it's like-
- I didn't know that.
- Noon, lunch, okay.
- It's like 8:30. .
So he comes in, they
pulled him off a plane
going to Oakland.
So he is coming in and he's fired up,
"All right, what do I do?"
I go, voice, good.
Voice is good.
(audience laughs)
Good, check that.
He goes, and he takes his jacket off,
huh, shoulders forever.
(audience laughs)
- Check.
- Check, and then he looked,
I went, good looking.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Nice, I didn't expect that,
you know, 'cause he is a boxer.
- [Kelly] Tough.
- And then we start,
and tough, then we started to
get up and I'm telling you,
and he goes, pow, pow, pow.
I go damn.
(audience and Kelly chuckles)
It's like a woodpecker hit me.
- [Kelly] Oh my god.
- Check, and then he goes,
"I would've done better if you
at least hired a real actor,
instead of, what do
you, what's this guy do,
work in the office?"
"No, he's Rocky."
He went, "All right, how you doing Rocky?"
(Kelly and audience laughs)
He's like, and I go-
- This guy.
- Arrogant, got it.
Which you needed, you know what I mean?
I wanted that.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I wanted him to have
this like Muhammad Ali.
He had it all, he had charm,
he had this, he had heart,
he had soul.
So I was stunned when it happened.
I was like crushed.
I didn't think he would ever die.
You know, he's like superman.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah.
So I look back now with
fond, fond, fond memories
'cause it's never gonna happen.
You know when have you
have those seminal moments,
those crossroads?
It's like
- Yep. A certain chemistry
on certain things, yeah.
- It's impossible to duplicate.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know,
it's like if they take a group
and let's say the Rolling Stones, right?
You take Mick Jagger out, it's over.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You take Mick Jagger as a solo,
I don't think it works either.
There's something about that
combination that was so unique
that you can't mess with it.
- Yeah.
- And I think that happened with Rocky.
Everybody in it was like sort
of born to play the part.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
I love it, and when it
works out like that,
that's why it's so successful.
- Yeah, it is, it is.
(audience cheering)
- His Netflix documentary is called "Sly"
and the new season of
his Paramount+ series,
"The Family Stallone"
starts February 21st.
The show also stars his family.
So everybody let's welcome them right now.
Please say hello to Scarlet,
Sistine and Sophia Stallone
and their mama Jennifer Flavin Stallone.
(audience cheering)
(upbeat instrumental music)
Oh my gosh, welcome to the show.
It's like no one unattractive
is allowed in your family.
(family laughs)
Like the whole damn family is attractive.
- Thank you.
- Makes my life very hard.
- Beautiful, yes.
Well, your life was already hard.
I'm looking at four women
that you had in your house
for many years.
That couldn't have been easy.
But speaking of like home life,
y'all just moved to Florida?
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- Oh, we love it.
I love it.
- Why the move?
- Because our older two
daughters moved to New York
and then our younger daughter
goes to college in Florida.
So we thought...
- They follow us everywhere.
- I love it.
- We couldn't, you know,
it was such a long flight.
So we just thought
- [Kelly] It is
- we can move a little closer.
- Yeah, I didn't really realize that.
So I have to go to LA for
things and I'm like, oh my gosh.
- It's a five and a half
hour, six hour flight.
- [Kelly] I'm not 20 anymore.
- I know.
- I was like, what?
What do you, do you like when
they come visit in New York,
do you like?
- No.
(audience laughs)
- I'm gonna be honest,
I'm gonna be honest.
- She said no.
She goes, yeah, no.
- Don't be vague.
- I don't wanna lie, I don't
wanna lie on your show.
I don't wanna lie.
My mom, love her, she's
OCD with cleanliness
and my dad tries to fix things.
For example, we had a
lamp with no light bulb.
So we unscrewed another
lamp to put it in this one.
And then that one had no light bulb.
So he tries to help.
- Well wait, did you
not use the other one?
Is that why?
- (group exclaiming) we used all of them.
- But he makes things a
little more difficult.
- [Sylvester] Excuse me.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- It's on you guys, two light bulbs.
It's really easy.
- [Kelly] . Don't buy more light bulbs
that's what he's thinking.
All right, so you live
with a lot of women, man.
So like did you have like a man cave?
- Lucky guy, lucky guy.
- [Kelly] Lucky guy, yeah.
- Yeah.
- But did you have a,
just a corner for you?
- I did, I did for about 10 minutes
and then it became.
- [Jennifer] Oh please.
(imitating playing a violin)
- The bear cave.
- Please, you guys, he had his man cave.
He had a big office where he'd write,
he had another man cave where
he'd sit and watch boxing.
- No, I didn't, it's a she cave now.
- He took over the entire garage
and made it an art studio for him.
So our cars were in the front yard
and he would just like
paint in the garage.
Trust me, he was fine.
- Oh my God.
- He was fine.
- They are such liars, it's unbelievable.
(crowd and Kelly laughing)
- This is the best television.
Your show is amazing.
- Oh my God, Pinocchios all of you.
- Pinocchio.
Oh my god, I love it.
I love cut to us having footage of like
exactly what they're saying.
- Yeah.
- So wait, you have a very athletic dad.
So did he like play sports?
- Oh.
- Oh yeah.
- We did every sport in high
school, every single one.
- Sistine broke the record for shot put.
- My dad thought before
school, and this is true,
every morning for about four
years, he'd wake us up early.
We'd have to do pushups,
sit-ups, swing a golf club,
throw a shot put, I
don't know why shot put.
That was
- [Sophia] Yeah that was a weird one.
- He said the only two things
he wanted us to do in life
was know how to swing a golf club
and know how to throw a shot put.
And I'm not sure what
the second one was about.
We were top shot putters in our grade.
I'm not sure why.
- You guys can throw a punch too.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, they can hit hard.
- Now that's a good thing to teach them.
You might need that one day.
- Yeah, never know.
- Not every guy's the right guy.
So did you ever give him any like,
mottoes to like live by, any
advice especially with dudes?
- Oh, well yes, actually I did.
I said think like a man.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- And act like a woman
and you'll figure it all out.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- You know, because we're not
that complicated.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- I mean, no, all you seriously, we just,
my wife makes me watch the
Housewives of everywhere.
- [Jennifer] Yeah.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- And I went, wow,
we have no chance.
- No.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I mean women are just active, they-
- I don't know that you
should necessarily compare
most of the women in the world
to the people on the show.
- No, no, no, no, yes I can.
- I don't know if that's-
- No, no.
What it is is you guys have
such command of the language.
I mean, you activate it, you talk.
Men just can sit there at a football game,
go, how you doing, how are you doing?
And that's it for three hours.
- No, now I'll tell you this, man,
I went to the Super Bowl one time.
This clown's talking me the
whole time and it was a dude.
And I was like, I did not
come here to meet you.
I was like, I am watching the game.
So some of us just saying.
- Yeah, you have a couple
friends that never stop
talking, Sly.
You fall asleep and go to bed and
- [Kelly] You're stuck with them.
- I'm stuck with them.
(audience laughing)
- That's true.
- That's me.
I would leave.
I'd be like,
it's time for bed.
- I do leave.
- And sneak upstairs.
- I've actually called
the police a couple times.
- To be like, go home.
- For the noise, I go,
there's a lot of noise
coming from the Stallone house.
And the cops will show up and
I'm upstairs in the bedroom
watching a Western.
- So wait, I got it, okay.
Sistine, so is this a true story?
- Uh-oh.
- Did your father like
throw you into sharks
at some point in your life?
- See, it sounds crazy and unfortunately-
- Well it sounds like someone should
have called child services.
- [Sistine] It's true.
- But yeah.
- Fair enough.
It's true.
It was a controlled
environment, it was very safe.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Swimming with the sharks experience.
And my dad, I was
seriously afraid of them.
He thought it'd be funny to
throw some chum in my one piece
and shove me right in.
- And she's also a horrible swimmer.
- And I'm a bad swimmer.
So it was just a really, I
don't think I talked to you
the rest of the trip.
I was very upset.
- No, you didn't.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- I wanted to see if the sharks bite.
- No, you did not.
- I got two other daughters.
- I got two other daughters, thank you.
The fact that he was like,
I'm gonna put chum in there.
- I know.
Well now I know where I
stand on the leader board.
- Have you gotten him back?
- I did something a little naughty.
First season.
- [Sylvester] A little?
- I pretended I was pregnant.
- Can you imagine?
- [Sistine] I did.
- On camera.
- I mean on camera so it, you know?
- She made a birthday cake with
all these goofy baby parts.
- No, but by the way,
Kelly, it was my mom's idea.
So that was,
(audience laughing)
- Yeah, I liked doing it.
- Baby parts like, you know,
- Actually thought he was
gonna have a heart attack, and
I kept saying
- Like Freddy Krueger.
- By the way, it was on his birthday.
- Oh my gosh.
I love your women so much and your family.
- We gotta dish it back, you know?
- I know.
You threw her into sharks with chum.
- I did.
- I'm like you, she gets
like five more things.
- Thank you, thank you.
- [Kelly] Like that's horrifying.
- You guys kept saying,
oh they don't bite.
I go, it's a shark.
Maybe you have one there
that has emotional problems.
- By the way, we all got in the water.
Guess who stayed on the boat
- The whole time.
- For sure.
- He did not
- [Sylvester] For sure.
- He didn't put his toe in the water.
We all swam with them the whole time.
- You can have the water,
I'm staying on the land, the
shark, you know what I mean?
I'm far enough already.
- What were your like, initial thoughts?
'Cause this is letting
people in your lives.
So what were your initial
thoughts about this?
- I think we all were a little nervous.
- Yeah.
- And we are all thinking, oh my God,
are people gonna like us,
hate us and make fun of us?
- I hated the idea.
- Yeah, he hated.
And then I go, oh, is
that a closeup of me?
(all laughing)
- [Kelly] Damn, I'm handsome.
- That's true, that's true.
Now it's like, we can't
get him off the camera.
I'm like, aren't you tired of
being in front of the camera?
- It's very addictive.
- Sharing a little bit.
- It's addictive.
- It's a, it's a burden
and a love, I love that
- It's a blessing and a curse.
- Yeah.
What about y'all, what about being on,
- [Sistine] What about you Scar?
- Well, I was really nervous
to do it, but I know Sophia
and Sistine really wanted to
do it 'cause of their podcast.
And then they love like talking
to people and connecting with them.
So they were like,
might as well just bring
the whole family in
and just start a show.
- Yeah, you can't stop us from talking.
We are always talking.
We thought it'd be fun
to include our family
because we're different.
This is like a very
unorthodox kind of family
with why would we do a reality show?
Like we don't really need to,
but we're all pretty funny
here and we love like
how much love we show
and we think, oh, why
don't we just film it
for like a home movie
for the world to see.
- Just the stuff your dad
does to you is worth telling.
- Yeah that's what I'm saying, yeah,
- We were like normal.
- Yeah, exactly.
- It's now, see I say this,
my friends think I'm nuts,
but I'm always like, prepare yourself.
Like, oh, you're walking
home when, well buddy system.
Like I am constantly
mothering all my friends.
- Oh you have no idea.
- No, he like waits up for them.
Yeah I sit and he'll call them and say,
you know, you're supposed
to be home by 11:30.
And they're like, we're coming home.
And he's like, no, no, you
need to be in the car at 11,
so you're in your bed at 11:30.
There's no like walking through.
- [Kelly] See that's different.
- I hate it with boyfriends and,
- [Kelly] Oh.
I really shook them up, every one of them.
- [Kelly] I can't, that's
- I was bad.
- [Sistine] He was bad.
- I crushed their hands, it was terrible.
- I hate it for you.
Like, I can't even imagine
bringing a dude home to that.
- I would sneak 'em around like
different doors of the house, like
- She was the boyfriend's friends.
She'd always find a
way to help us out like
so we could actually have a relationship.
- Like have a real life.
- And the only one that has
- I saw nine guys walking upstairs and go,
excuse me,
- Okay.
- Yeah, it's bad enough there's one.
- No, no, no
- Was that like a bachelor
(talking over each other)
- No they had nine guys
coming up to the room
and our cabapoos.
- Hold on, hold on.
(talking over each other)
- No, no, no.
No, they were like 13 years old, but
- Listen, summer vacation
I had all my friends over,
they're making it sound like I was alone
with nine men in my room.
- [Jennifer] No but I
- We were fifteen.
- We saw all these boys
- [Sistine] Oh my god.
- walking up to her bedroom
and I was just like,
nine is better than one.
- Hell yeah.
- And I go, no it ain't.
(all laughing)
It's nine times the problem
So I hold the door, I
put furniture against it,
they can't close the door
- [Kelly] Oh there has to be an open door.
- And blare that television.
- Yeah it was an open door policy I think.
- Oh my god.
- Oh yeah, oh yeah, are you kidding me.
- That must be so hard, and you
know every dude is just like
I'm sorry your dad is who?
- Yeah.
- [Sylvester] Exactly.
- Wait 'til this new
season speaking of boys,
this new season is about
a boyfriend, right?
- Yes
- So a lot of it's about yeah.
- Yeah so basically, my
new boyfriend and I, Louie,
he comes into the picture and I remember
bringing him over for
the first time to film,
and he's never been over to my
house or anything like that,
so he walks in, there's
five cameras on him,
and he goes, (laughing) "Oh god".
And he comes in and
there's five cameras on him
and he goes "What a family".
(nervous laughing)
- Oh my god, well you warned him right?
- I, kind of but it,
you know it's (laughing)
I didn't want to scare him off.
- [Sistine] It's better
if you don't say anything.
- Yeah, just let it happen.
- Yeah.
- I didn't want to scare him
off, I like him too much and,
they like him too.
- [Jennifer] He's so lovely]
- Especially Sly.
- Especially Sly, right Sly. (laughing)
- You like him, he's a good kid.
- [Kelly] It's the one
time you've been quiet.
- I know.
No I (soft growling)
(audience laughing)
I do like him, I like him.
Nice hair.
(all laughing)
Good guy, very nice.
- [Kelly] Oh god.
- Whenever he comes over,
you steal him away from me.
- I will say, I don't know if anyone,
well he does that on purpose
so he's not with you.
(all laughing)
- [Scarlet] That's so true.
- But I dunno, I think
like, for parents in general
it's hard to see anyone worthy
of this kid that you love.
- [Jennifer] Right.
- So it's love, it can
appear controlling sometimes
but it is love. (laughing)
- I agree.
- All right, well give
it up for the Stallones,
my new favorite show on television.
(audience cheering)
Season two of their Paramount+
series "The Family Stallone"
starts February 21st so
please go and check out the
new documentary "Sly" on Netflix.